reading this like New Age horoscope
weird book called pronoia but the idea
was this cool message pronoia is the
antidote to paranoia
so paranoia is you connect the dots and
everything is against you as your
conclusion paranoia is you connect the
dots and everything is serving you which
interpretation would you choose and so
do we have agency over that
interpretation
there's certainly predisposition you
know past trauma can make you look at
everything that's happening in the
future is dangerous right trauma makes
the past over determine the present and
conjure up a future that becomes
identified with death or chaos right
David Lentz and says that bad trips on
drugs are just exaggerated versions of
the same thing right
a pre-existing fear you had about the
experience over determines the effects
of the drug and conscious of a future of
oh I'm going crazy or I'm going to die
it's just an amplified exaggeration of
what we do when were already anxious
which is formed by past experiences but
you can change those past experiences by
changing your interpretive frameworks
one of my most popular videos was can
you change the past and the idea was you
know epigenetics has to do with the
effects that experiences have on your
physiology experience shapes biology but
let's say you do an MDMA therapy session
like they're like okay great great so
there's an organization called in
multidisciplinary Association of
psychedelic studies which just got
granted phase 3 clinical trials
designated breakthrough therapy using
MDMA to help people with treatment
resistant PTSD yeah so people who've
been in war and are not responding to
medication so what they do this
particular technology puts people in
what they call the optimal arousal zone
so it quiets the amygdala which is the
fear response which is trying to protect
you from impending doom quiets that
while boosting activity in the frontal
cortex so you can think rationally about
things then it simultaneously engages
you because it's a methamphetamine while
simultaneously making you feel relaxed
as you're more engaged they call that
the Goldilocks it's just like planet
Earth just close enough to the Sun
too much and that optimal arousal zone
is great for cognitive reframing it's
like you can think back about the
experience you can be like okay that
sucked
that was one isolated experience it
doesn't condemn me to have future
experiences like that and that sort of
realignment and cognitive reframing and
rhe patterning of the memory changes the
past experience in the sense that it
changes the physiological effects that
it's having on your present moment so
maybe you're not getting the cortisol
anymore you're not getting the anxiety
secreting chemicals anymore and so
you're effectively cured so I would say
that that changing those interpretive
frameworks and exercising agency over
that and realizing that you can do that
is the best intervention thank you
[Applause]